welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and it's time to put a
smile on that face with some amazing
batman easter eggs
that are just some of the coolest
details we've ever seen throughout this
video we're going to be discussing
everything that you need to snow about
them
whilst also delivering some ice puns
you'll absolutely
love don't even think that last one
works however there might be some things
you don't want to know here
so i suggest you sled off to avoid
potentially having the movie room for
you
we're pretty much the edward snowden of
spoilers
zoraxia i caught that was so i'm sorry
that was so bad
anyway without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so the first easter egg we need to
discuss is the superman extra that was
seen walking around set last night
this christopher reeves costume brings a
lot with it and it has so many things we
can read into
whilst it could also mean absolutely
nothing at all
what it does mean though is that in the
mat reeves batman universe
superman exists in some form or another
now reeves has said that this is going
to be a very grounded betrayal
and so far everything we've seen has
carried a lot of real weight to it
the trailer was especially good at
setting this up and while this is the dc
universe
i do think that this superman may be
riffing on a comic book character in the
world
or maybe the christopher reeves film
exists in the mat reeves continuity
i think that this easter egg has been
placed in here not as a confirmation or
denial of that
but rather as just well an easter egg
in its purest form in my opinion warner
brothers and reeves
likely have some ideas for what they
want to do with the franchise down the
line
and maybe they're just putting this
entities that superman could be out and
about there in the world
or if they decide to change their mind
at some point just make him some cool
little comic book character like the man
of steel that we know and love
now what this likely is is that it's
taking place at the halloween party
we know was gtb film before lockdown
came into place
there were a lot of calls for extras and
costumes and it seems like this is
pretty much what's happening at this
moment
as there were also several other people
spotted in
in very nice dc getups unless this is
what batman and superman now look like
because
because the movies run out of money
which if they have
they should put it on ice hey it's a way
i tell them now speaking of ice
we also have a cool little mr freeze
easter egg that popped up on one of the
flyers that was seen dotted about the
shooting locations
we're gonna be talking about a lot of
these in the video as they've been used
as set dressing to bring everything to
life
whilst keeping it in line with the
universe now shout outs to the bat
robert
which i hope is a play on the bat report
as they found one of these related to
goth corp
aka the company that mr freeze works for
the flyer says stab out the eye of goth
corp so i'm guessing that it's one of
the riddler's gang
or even the villain himself trying to
bring a little anarchy to the
corporation
gothcorp featured heavily in the batman
the animated series episode heart of ice
and they were actually the company that
not only provided funding to his wife's
treatment
but were also responsible for the
accident that turned him into mr freeze
i would love if in some way riddler
causing an uprising against
the company also caused his wife's
cryogenic chamber to be destroyed
and this would mean that he was
responsible for freeze falling into the
vat
that changed him into the infamous
villain now the movie is probably far
too stacked as it is to have this in
but we do know there's going to be a
gotham central tv show coming down the
line
and one of the best arcs in that comic
book series actually centers around mr
freeze
i would love it if riddler's uprising
somehow caused the villain to be created
and then that tied into the gotham
central tv show which would help just to
flesh out the universe massively
it looks like there's going to be a ton
of hints towards villains and the
greater world too
as we did spot some more flyers that
also mention fear on them
this is obviously hinting towards
scarecrow's fear toxin
which is a massive weapon in the batman
universe now just in case you missed our
last video
we did theorize that barracuy and aka
stanley merkel
may actually be a big batman villain who
was masquerading as a policeman
whilst also dealing drops on the side we
say
that these drops would be things like
the fear toxin and joker gas
which he had stolen from the evidence
room and then started dealing on the
streets
we have seen signs for drops and the
health warnings that come with them
and the logo that was shown on them is
now side by side with the fierce city
symbol
big bad theory was the guy that first
brought this all to our attention
and i definitely think it leans towards
our thinking on the movie
though we could be completely wrong now
another thing that's really interesting
is that amongst these posters is one
that has a huge smile on it
and a tiered up set of eyes as we said
if our theory on the drops being linked
about the fear toxin and joker's
laughing gas is true
then it does make sense why the health
department are so worried about it
you have one variation that could send
people spiraling off into their own
worst nightmare
and another which if used incorrectly
can make the person laugh
uncontrollably until they die i think
it's absolutely amazing that they're
dropping stuff in like this to flesh out
the villains
but we also have something that looks
like it could be referencing the heroes
too
amongst the litter is a piece of paper
that says something along the lines of
f you headlick sidekick great escape is
for the weak
to the end mad looking for sanity now
shout out to chris from 3c films for
bringing attention to the word psychic
which does hint towards the the little
bird pal
that hangs around with batman i don't
think that robin will feature in this
movie
or you know pop up anytime soon
but it is good that they drop these cool
little things on set
that fans will absolutely eat up eat up
and make 800 videos a week on other
things at the set that have been caught
are a sign that says broke
which was put up outside the courthouse
and there was also a newscast running in
which mayoral candidate bella real
was being interviewed this seems to be
the same program that bruce is watching
in the batcave
during the trailer and though we don't
know exactly what they're talking about
with the mayor being confirmed as dead
in the movie it does make sense that she
would be interviewed over what her
thoughts on the situation are
and finally we've got some more footage
of the batman glider scene
it looks like it's gonna be an amazing
part of the film
firstly f the sun as it's the worst
newspaper in the world
but also it looks like the scene will be
taking place at night
and they've been practicing it all day
and every day kind of going over the
stance that batman will be having before
he jumps off the building
and goes to who knows where anyway
that's pretty much all of the updates on
the film
and with it being such a stacked week
for batman news
i don't think it'll be too long before
we find out something else in regards to
the film
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the behind the scenes looks
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
want something else to watch
and also check out our breakdown of the
other behind the scenes images that we
have linked at the end
we discuss the potential mad hatter
easter eggs in more detail
and also go about why we think the
tribune tower that's being filmed this
weekend
is actually wayne tower don't forget
we're giving away three copies of the
marvel phase one box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of october so make sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on our discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best
i've been pulled i'll see you next time
take care peace
you